[Music]  the new eu citizens equality rights and  values funding program is the biggest eu  fund ever for the promotion and  protection of rights and values it has  over 1.55 billion euros allocated for  the period between 2021 and 2027 to  empower organizations across europe to  help build a union of equality  we are looking for projects that promote  gender equality combat gender-based  violence and violence against children  and projects that fight racism  xenophobia and other forms of  discrimination  does your organization work on  protecting and promoting the rights of  persons with disabilities or lgbtiq  people does your organization work for  the inclusion of roma people in all  aspects of society if it does then this  is the fund for you check it out  [Music]  you